alors ça fait déjà trois semaines condé
sur la réforme des retraites à
l'assemblée nationale
et il se passe peu de chose
malheureusement alors que ça concerne
toutes les françaises tous les français
les retraités d'aujourd'hui les
retraités de demain
on est dans une forme de blocage où les
oppositions en particulier l'extrême
gauche empêche la majorité d'avancé dans
le texte empêche même les autres
oppositions d'avancé dans le texte donc
tout le monde est assez frustré alors 49
trop opaque 49,3 en fait le 49 3 en
général c'est quand la majorité est un
peu gêné aux entournures et que on
n'arrivera pas à avoir une majorité pour
voter un texte en l'occurrence la
majorité elle est unie entre modem et
lrm et elle est même plus large que ça
parce que la bonne surprise d'avoir
aujourd'hui des députés agir des députés
eu 10 des députés non-inscrits qui sont
prêts à soutenir la réforme pense
qu'effectivement il faut dépasser le
blocage parlementaire
je ne prône pas je le redoute parce que
c'est dommage de ne pas pouvoir
travailler sur le texte mais on serait
plutôt dans un 49,3 à l'envers une sorte
de 3,49 pour dépasser l'obstruction de
l'opposition
si tel est le cas le texte ira au sénat
le sénat va probablement beaucoup
l'abîmé parce que là l'extrême gauche de
l'assemblée nationale aura confié à la
droite sénatoriale le soin de faire
évoluer le texte
ils vont nous le fit ionisé est bien
quand il reviendra à l'assemblée
nationale au printemps on pourra le rhum
acronis et il faut que nous au modem on
remette de la clarté dans le débat qu'on
leur dise non préalable les prahlad
qu'on avait affirmé d'ailleurs des
guides elle parce que nous analyse bien
c'est clair sur le sujet c'est un les
pensions doivent pas baisser aussi bien
pour les retraités d'aujourd'hui pour
les retraités de demain
2 les droits acquis sont acquis tout ce
qui a été accumulée dans le système
d'avant vous faudra évidemment dans le
système d'après 3 on touche pas aux
réserves ce qui peut considérablement
rassurer les avocats on remet déjà des
préalables pour que tout le monde
retrouve un peu de sérénité dans le pays
et puis après il faut dire ce qu'on veut
mettre en plus comme plus value sociale
dans ce texte
la première chose c'est sur la
gouvernance il faut que les syndicats
soient inclus dans la gouvernance avec
soin une gouvernance vraiment
démocratique partagé entre le politique
et le syndical
la deuxième chose c'est la pénibilité il
y avait
des bons pas qui avait été fait par le
passé dans la pénibilité mais qui était
très difficile à appliquer nous on a
trouvé la solution en discutant
d'ailleurs avec la cftc et avec la cfdt
c'est de pouvoir déterminer la
pénibilité par branche et au que ce soit
fait par statut ou par entreprise qu'on
puisse vraiment s'adapter à la situation
de chacun troisième priorité la famille
parce qu'aujourd'hui on va améliorer les
droits familiaux avec des pourcentages
de retraite supplémentaire pour les
femmes qui ont eu des enfants
mais il faut qu'on aille plus loin pour
le troisième enfant et plus loin sur le
deuxième enfant
d'abord parce que la famille a beaucoup
évolué et aujourd'hui et puis aussi
parce qu'on a une crise de la natalité
dans notre pays et que si on veut un
système de retraite qui va être garantie
à long terme il faut qu'on soit en
capacité d'avoir plus d'enfants demain
et donc de mieux les accompagner
jamais le problème financier soit un
obstacle à un projet familial d'avoir un
enfant et puis je dirais aussi une autre
priorité qui est une vraie avancée
sociale pour ce texte c'est la retraite
progressive est la transmission en fin
de carrière il faut qu'ils arrivent à la
fin de sa carrière quand on est au
summum de sa compétence professionnelle
n'est pas au summum de ses capacités
physiques
on travaille un peu moins pour
transmettre beaucoup plus